Fox News host Chris Wallace has enraged
the Fox News audience by sort of
piercing their narrative about no
collusion no obstruction the entire
Muller probe was a witch-hunt started
with a bogus bogus dossier talking point
we've debated before on the show how
much value there is in having these
occasional voices of reason on Fox News
and the argument usually goes on the one
hand it's good when Chris Wallace or
Shep Smith or whoever say something
that's just kind of an uncontroversial
truth in in most of the world on Fox
News because it will kind of awaken
their audience to the reality that there
are other perspectives on what the Trump
administration and is doing and that's a
good thing
the counter-argument is that when you
have occasionally Shep Smith or Chris
Wallace say some grain of truth on fox
news it kind of provides cover to Fox
News to be able to say we're fair and
balanced we have a diversity of views we
have Chris Wallace and Shep Smith see
we're doing it were fair and balanced
and the reality is that even when Chris
Wallace or Shep Smith say some basic
truth about the Trump administration
they're not challenging the sort of
propaganda corporate media status quo
and may even help to sort of reinforce
it but my position historically has been
I think it's a net positive it's a net
positive despite of being maybe a small
one - occasionally pierce the narrative
of Fox News viewers with someone there
who will tell some minor truth so that
gets us to chris wallace over the
weekend chris wallace said something
that is obviously true and undeniable at
this point but it has thrown the fox
news audience into a rage Wallace said
that when Rush Limbaugh was recently
interviewed on Fox News about the end of
the Moller probe Rush Limbaugh said that
the entire thing started with that phony
dossier written by Christopher Steele
the British X British intelligence
agency that has been repeated a bunch of
times now it's already been widely
debunked Rush Limbaugh said it and Chris
Wallace simply said that's not true
and it has thrown Fox News viewers into
a rage take a look you're exactly right
whether the report comes out because
particularly on obstruction it's not a
clean bill of health
you know it did bar ended up saying he
didn't think there was a basis for
prosecution but exactly as you point out
they're gonna be able to say well you
know he did this or that this happened
and there was only one other point I do
want to make and I know this was gonna
drive some of our viewers nuts the Trump
investigation did not start with the
FISA warrant and Carter page and even
the dossier it started in June and July
of 2016 when George papadopolis had
spoken to a Russian agent and spoke to
an Australian diplomat and said he had
heard that they had information on dirt
on Hillary Clinton that's when the
investigation started so it was in
October
it wasn't September it was in July and
was George papadopolis not to say that
the Pockett were just a legitimate basis
let me just finish yeah not a legitimate
basis for inquiry but that is not where
the investigation started it's funny
that Chris Wallace he knows in advance
that the Fox News audience is so rabid
and disconnected from reality that he
says he knows it's going to drive their
audience nuts for him to say something
so uncontroversial and obviously truths
it's like he gave him a trigger warning
I'm about to tell the truth Chris
Wallace announces and it's going to
trigger the Fox News audience the Trump
is narrative so I'm gonna warn you that
I'm about to tell the truth Wallace says
the investigation actually started when
Trump associates spoke to Russians about
the 2016 election that's true and what a
lot of people are missing about this
entire narrative if you didn't know that
there were people claiming the whole
thing started with a FISA warrant then I
envy you I mean I wish I didn't know
that this is something people were
saying but investigations don't start
with FISA warrants right they keep
repeating this idea but a FISA warrant
is an investigative technique or a
mechanism investigations don't start
with FISA warrants FISA warrants are
issued for investigations that
ready stand on their own and not
surprisingly Pat the smears of Chris
Wallace immediately starred for just
telling uncontroversial truths to the
audience and you gotta love what Bill
Hemmer did there which is just to
completely try to shut down Chris
Wallace make sure that what Chris
Wallace had to say was not going to get
out there on the airwaves you got the
sense that Bill Hemmer knew that people
up at the Fox News executive offices and
people watching Fox News back home we're
not going to like what Chris Wallace had
to say there yeah Bill Hemmer couldn't
resist he said and I like when chris
wallace actually says hey let me let me
finish let me finish this completely
mild milquetoast defense of just one
element of all of the crazy things that
rush limbaugh tried to say so this this
is why I questioned the kind of real
value of these occasional voices of
reason on Fox because in the same
segment Wallace still does go along with
a bunch of nonsense related to the bar
report without questioning it but just
this like one little point he questions
and Bill Hemmer doesn't like it and the
Fox News audience doesn't like it so I
guess we can say it's good in general
that at least he corrected one point but
big picture Chris Wallace is part of the
apparatus and we can't really expect any
serious critique of the status quo from
him or whoever else there is on Fox News
let me know what you think I think it's
a mild net positive to have him there
every once in a while saying something
that's true there's something really
ugly developing that I want to talk
about and it has to do with two people
it has to do with our friend Ana
Kasparian over at the Young Turks
and it also has to do with 2020
candidate Tulsi Gabbard and it kind of
also has to do with cults of personality
which I've talked about before I've
talked about how these cults of
personality can develop around
politicians and generally it's just not
good spirited enthusiastic support of
candidates that you think will be good
for America that's great we want that we
want people to be engaged we want people
advocating for people in policies that
they think are going to bring positive
change who could possibly criticize that
engaging in a respectful and sort of
issues oriented
even if there are strong disagreements
that's great I'm all for it it's what I
do
this show is built around that idea but
when the behavior starts to become
obsessive and it turns into a cult of
personality generally speaking it's bad
and we should call it out when that's
going on we saw this and we still see it
around Donald Trump and his followers
there's a serious cult of personality
around Donald Trump and you can often
tell because when you criticize Trump
policy the blowback from his supporters
is ad hominem it's talking points and
memes and personal attacks and insults
there's no doubt that there was a sort
of cult of personality around george w
bush it's not just the right there are a
cult of personality around people that
are ostensibly on the left if you go
back to the 2016 election Jill Stein I
would criticize Jill Stein on issues and
the blowback would be I'm an
establishment shill smearing Jill Stein
I'm a Jew who can't see the truth like
Jill Stein is able to all of this stuff
there was a slight cult of personality
around Bernie in 2016
now not all Bernie supporters in fact
most did not sort of support Bernie in
this way I was a Bernie supporter in
2016 but there was this enclave of the
sort of Bernie or bust movement that had
a component of that toxic cult of
personality so these cults exist on the
Left they exist on the right and right
now I'm seeing it with tulsi gabbard
every time I critique tulsi gabbard the
level of vitriol and toxicity that is in
the comments and reactions is notable
attacks against me claims that I'm
smearing without actually refuting any
of the assertions that I make factually
so I was really interested when last
week ana kasparian from The Young Turks
did an episode of no filter where she
has previously critiqued and analyzed
multiple 20/20 candidates she did a
segment about Tulsi Gabbard this segment
was good I tweeted the segment it was
filled with fact-based critiques as ana
kasparian saw them based on things that
Tulsi
a bird has said or things that she's
done or based on how she voted there
were no ad homonyms from ana there were
no smears the video got mostly dislikes
more dislikes than likes and it got a
ton ton ton of comments that are just
disgusting stuff like Anna's a hack
she's spewing propaganda she's an
aborted three-year-old
this is an attack on Tulsi Ana's not
really progressive anna loves isis I
could go on just telling you the stuff
that was said but you probably get the
idea so far nothing is surprising okay
this is we've seen this around a tulsi
gabbard since she announced her
candidacy so the next thing that happens
is that our friend Jen huger from The
Young Turks interviews Tulsi Gabbard in
the Young Turks studio a few days after
Anna's video is put out and it's notable
that Anna isn't part of the interview
genk is interviewing Tulsi Gabbard anna
has been part of other interviews that
TYT has done with 20/20 contenders and
politicians who visit their studio but
Anna's not there and this leads to even
more smears of Anna by Tosi Gabbard
supporters Anna is bad because she
refused to participate in the interview
with Tulsi Gabbard and it turns out that
Tulsi Gabbard presumably as a result of
the video Anna did last week said that
Tulsi would not participate in the
interview if Anna participates that Anna
should not be part of the interview with
Tulsi Gabbard Anna followed up about
this and actually said the following in
a reaction video yesterday take a look
although I would have loved to ask
Gabbard about the issues raised in my
previous episode of no filter I was
informed by her camp that I would not be
part of the interview she had with TYT
last Friday it was surprising and a very
surprising demand considering no other
candidate had done the same regardless
of how critical I've been about their
positions in the past I've said multiple
times that true leaders put themselves
in uncomfortable positions when it's the
right thing to do and answering the
questions I had
was the right thing to do Jake you were
conducted a great interview and I highly
recommend you all check out the full
conversation on t Whitey's YouTube page
but to set the record straight for those
who think I ran from that interview
understand that I was in the same room
watching as it took place it was the
first time any politician walked into my
home and told me that I wasn't allowed
to do my job so you can disagree with my
analysis you can have a different
perspective but you can't argue that I
smeared her without providing a single
example of me fabricating anything not
super empowering of women for Telsey to
say that woman who criticized me she
can't ask me any questions when I'm
there or I'm not participating so this
is not about Anna's perfect
Anna's right I agree with Anna about
some things I disagree about others I've
known her for many years at this point
and I have a sense of her politics and
her MO this is not about this is the
person whose politics I'm 100% in line
with although we have a lot of points of
agreement this is about unfair smears
that are examples of when the left
starts to eat itself
and the toxic cult of personality that
exists around tulsi gabbard now I'm sure
that if the Tulsi campaign were to give
a statement about this and maybe they
will I don't know my guess is they would
say oh well you know there it was there
were time constraints and Tulsi knows
jenk and they have a history already so
we felt it would be better for a
one-on-one interview it wasn't anything
against Anna we just felt that it would
be a bad interview best handle there's a
one-on-one whatever this is lame the
toxic and angry followers around Tulsi
Gabbard attacking Anna viciously are
disgusting and Ali every element of this
absolutely stinks and this is exactly
the type of thing that I talk about when
I talk about cults of personality when I
talk about arguments that aren't really
arguments attacking the messengers and
calling people shills and smears when
they are simply saying this is what the
person said and this is my
interpretation of that and everything
about this stinks and this is the type
of stuff that will lead to Donald Trump
being
elected Trump being reelected won't just
be because Tull sees followers attack
Tana okay I'm not being myopic or
childish in that way but this type of
thing developing around a particular
candidate it's just not good for the
left and if the number one priority is
removing Donald Trump from office this
is not the way to do it this is part of
a big bigger picture that is going to
make it not happen and give us four more
years of Donald Trump I have for you
today
one of the most cringe inducing
interviews I've seen in my time doing
this type of thing in online media in
broadcast media
so this apparently oh I have to back up
a little bit Candace Owens Candace Owens
is this sir fabricated black
conservative hero very well-funded she
has quickly become a darling of the pro
Trump right and she I guess has a new
show the show is part of the
outrageously right-wing Prager
University on YouTube connected with
outrageous right winger Dennis Prager so
I guess she has a show there now I don't
know how new it is I've never seen it
before I think it's pretty new yesterday
I saw the first episode of my life and
one of these first episodes contains an
interview with cultural critic Dave
Rubin okay the interview is a case study
in sophistry and faux intellectualism
but I don't even really want to call it
that it's not even phone intellectualism
no one would actually mistake it for
that it's more like faux faux
intellectualism it's faux
intellectualism that even fails to be
that if you can imagine and it was rife
with just a panoply of were not not even
just bad ideas but obviously dumb ideas
widely debunked ideas and I felt the
cringe like the hairs on my arms went up
because my body physically could not
tolerate the meaningless and vapid
nature of this discussion all framed as
reasonable people talking about ideas
and pointing out how terrible
and off the rails everybody else's
including of course primarily the
American left this is an hour long or an
hour and five or ten minutes long I
don't know that I would recommend that
you watch it all if you do you can put
it on to X speed on YouTube and get
through the bulk of it in like 25
minutes without including the first and
last minutes which are sort of like a a
wind up and a wind down where Dave Rubin
and Candace Owens just throw bouquets at
each other I'm not going to include any
of that here today so I'm just skipping
around this is not a comprehensive tour
of the interview you can randomly drop
in at any point during this thing and
you're gonna find a treasure trove of
absurdity but let's start with this
moment sort of early in the interview
where Candace Owens tells Dave Rubin
that she's going to confront him and
call him out and of course this is meant
to show that they're not scared of
disagreement everyone can respectfully
disagree and get along and no one gets
offended except what she wants to call
him out about is that he's simply too
smart to be a classical liberal he's too
smart to have the word liberal
associated with him at all even though
classical liberalism is very right-wing
so she wants to call him out Wow what
courage it took from Candice Owens take
a look I'm gonna call you out on
something
yes saying that you're a classical
liberal it's not physically nauseous
okay the whole world knows there's just
no way you're too practical you're too
smart you're not most people that's I'm
still learning we've watched yourself
okay you've spoken to so many people you
have an in-depth knowledge of things
that you've done stuff on on even it's
like a Daleks and they just you're like
a wealth of knowledge and yet you insist
on calling yourself a classical liberal
and it's cheap and it's ending today
well first off I want to thank you for
putting vodka in here help this portion
of the conversation okay so look I am a
classical liberal and I would argue if
we say if we sit here long enough I can
get you to admit that you're a classical
liberal to this is I I mean it's
difficult to watch it's real
difficult to watch you're just too smart
for being anything with the word liberal
in it of course totally ignorant of the
fact that small-l liberalism is not
progressivism in the sort of modern
American context and Rubin is right he
probably could convince her that she's a
classical liberalism classical liberal
because classical liberalism is just a
semantic game for conservatism or a
particular brand of it we did a long
expose about it I don't need to get into
it but conservatives now are playing
this sort of semantic game with
classical liberalism ok let's go to
another point where Candis Owens defends
Alex Jones now this is this is just
amazing
recently she said Hitler's problem was
going beyond Germany with his goals she
skipped over the killing of six million
Jews if Hitler had simply remained a
nationalist versus becoming a globalist
wrong use of the word globalist but it
doesn't matter then that would have been
a whole other thing and Hitler would
have been much more reasonable he or she
is defending Alex Jones if there's one
thing that I've learned and I'm
constantly growing and learning it's
just that I actually really have a
problem with the way that social media
has banned certain people like I again
I've probably watched 10 minutes of the
Alex Jones Show of info wars of his show
and it was the 10 minutes I was on it
when I first started right um and I sat
next to him and to be honest he kind of
is like a WWE style like screaming at
the mic and nothing that he said or at
least why I was sitting there again I
I'm ignorant I could be completing
ignorance here with something that is
worthy of being banned from every
platform and they're also banning people
in the ways in the ways they make income
and you can't use PayPal and you can't
you strike and my whole perspective is
that today you tomorrow me understand
what she's saying I've never seen any
Alex Jones except for the 10 minutes
when he was interviewing me and during
those 10 minutes he didn't say anything
that was ban worthy so therefore it's
wrong for him to be banned from any
platforms what about the persistent
peddling of conspiracy theories leading
to legal action against him what about
the multiple large-scale bullying
campaigns of individuals breaking every
element of the terms and conditions of
private companies who I thought Candace
would
or having their rights as private
companies to decide who's on their
platform and who isn't respected or does
she think that that's not to be
respected and it's so brilliant I might
be ignorant but in the ten minutes I was
on the Alex Jones Show which she claims
are the only ten minutes she's ever seen
she didn't see anything that justified a
ban of Alex Jones on any platform sounds
like she's super well placed to be the
person deciding what Alex Platt what
what platforms should be doing with Alex
Jones right I mean this is just idiocy
at the highest level then they go into
sort of race and IQ stuff again with
this totally bogus notion that the left
doesn't want to talk about so-called
biological realities it's all about
being real and a realist and they start
sort of dancing around it take a look
speaking of feminism no feminism and
trends to be like how's that gonna kind
of go in together because I thought
feminism classic feminism we want
equality with men and we've carved out
all these spaces for us and in sports
and now all of a sudden men can talk
about the pain or he can step into what
we're doing and beat us and everything
biologically right they can do that I
don't want men abusing women unless
they're wrestling them and saying thank
you so cold
yeah and it's insane to me that this is
oh this is okay this is even a debate or
discussion well this is I mean but this
is what they do they stake out crazy
positions and then they make you
negotiate backwards so like look the
worst player in the NBA the worst male
professional basketball player would be
the MVP of the WNBA that's exactly
that's just true I don't take some great
pleasure in saying yeah I remember there
was this woman when the so this is straw
Manning on multiple levels first of all
they're mostly talking about issues that
number one aren't really that important
like okay I agree that there is a
reasonable position to take that if you
were born biologically male does it make
sense for you to compete in wrestling
against individuals born biologically
female probably not it's not transphobic
but it's also not a big issue it's not a
significantly important
in our culture it doesn't connect to
listen if people born biologically men a
male can wrestle women then the next
thing you know I don't even know right I
mean this is straw Manning as in that in
the sense that these are not even really
the most important issues but it's also
straw Manning in that if you want to
talk about equality between men and
women it's not about people born
biologically male who get to wrestle
against women right that's not that
doesn't destroy feminism this is not
something that the left is even consumed
with many people don't think if you're
born biologically male people on the
left you should be able to wrestle women
and it's just really a not not a major
issue if you're talking about chess for
example where the division between men
and women is more because there are more
male grandmasters and you want to
incentivize women to participate and if
they are competing in a group that is
women when we've talked about this right
but if you're born biologically male and
you you are a trans woman and you want
to participate in women's chess who care
I mean it like of course that's
completely fine this is just not the
hill on which anyone is holding this
debate and they're pretending that
that's the case and then they get into
this biological realities farce that the
left just doesn't want to talk about
biological realities well when I
remember in the WNBA started there was
this woman Cynthia Cooper who played on
the Houston and I think they were the
Houston Comets and she was awesome she
was awesome but I remember thinking she
would be a scrub in the NBA you know I
mean because she was still small women
generally or smaller she wasn't really
that fast compared to the way a fast man
is these are these are just biological
realities and they don't want us to be
able to talk about biological realities
I I don't like seeing those pictures
when I see a transact lete so a male to
female trans athlete joking a woman and
then I see the women on the left and the
women's March and and that through the
feminists defending that because they've
created this intersectional pyramid
where now trans is sort of above female
and Islam is above that and
is about that and this is about that
this is just so stupid right who could
watch this and say you know what that's
really insightful and interesting this
is a clinic on straw Manning they've set
up and agreed upon false pillars of
feminism and trans rights and now
they're in their echo chamber agreeing
about how bad it is that the left
doesn't want to talk about this stuff
they've set the parameters of the debate
in a fraudulent way this is not the real
debate that is happening and then they
critique it this is how an echo chamber
works and a you know but by the way the
whole they don't want to talk about
biological realities there is no
biological reality that the left in
total doesn't want to talk about you can
find individuals who have views that are
wacky and there are plenty of
individuals on the right that have wacky
views usually when they talk about
biological realities they eventually get
to race an IQ and we know the biological
realities there they are not the
realities of the so-called race realists
and it's not that the left isn't
allowing a conversation about it that
it's been widely researched we're bored
by it at this point insisting that black
people are Dumber because they are black
on the basis of IQ tests it's old news
it's boring and you're not someone who
is shutting down debate because you're
sick of the old tired debunk debate so
that's a little bit of the show it's
stunning that I think in some
conservative circles what you just saw
counts as like nuanced discussion if you
were to parody such an interview if you
were to parody an interview between
candace owens and dave rubin it would be
identical I mean it's indistinguishable
from a parody of itself and it also
important to mention they talk about the
free market of ideas this is not the
free market because these are really
well-funded operations Prager you which
is extraordinarily well funded brought
in Candace Owens and now she's in this
position whereas wow she's really this
is the free market it's not she was
forced upon people by organizations like
Turning Point USA and prayed or you and
they don't even yeah they're not even
subscribing to the principles they claim
to let me know what you think I'm on
twitter at Deepak
show is on twitter at david pakman show
i don't really know how to explain this
but donald trump appears not to know or
to be lying about where his father was
born which is a really weird thing I
mean I'm sort of struggling for the
language to apply here when Donald Trump
said that nambia was a country could
have been a verbal slip he probably just
doesn't have a firm grasp on African
countries and geography and that would
sort of be expected a lot of people
don't have a firm grasp on African
geography when Donald Trump said he's
done more than any president ever for
Puerto Rico he might not know that he's
been a disaster on Puerto Rico it might
be a political calculation in some way
maybe he forgot that he actually hasn't
been that great for Puerto Rico but
Donald Trump has claimed again that his
father was born in Germany and his
father wasn't born in Germany Donald
Trump's grandfather was born in Germany
and this is raising more questions about
cognitive decline I don't bring this up
to make fun of people cognitive declines
not funny
but if the president is suffering from
cognitive decline or pre dementia we
need to know that that that's a major
problem and Donald Trump could could
sort of be dissociating here
he's moving information around in his
mind as people in various stages of
cognitive decline sometimes do it's his
grandfather who's actually German but he
says that it was his father check out
this video from the Oval Office and if
you notice if you're watching this thing
happens that's common in people who
start to struggle cognitively but are
still in the early stages he starts to
say his dad was born in Germany but if
you're looking at the reaction on his
face he seems to sort of recognize that
something he's saying isn't quite right
it's almost like internal Trump is
recognizing that external Trump is doing
something a little bit weird and it's
not clear whether his mind can totally
parse it I mean this is sad take a look
at this I mean Germany honestly is not
paying their fair share I've great
respect for Angela and I have great
respect for the country my
father is German right was German and
born in a a very wonderful place in
Germany I so I have a great feeling for
Germany but they're not paying what they
should be paying yeah so trump's dad
Fred Trump was born in New York I mean
he wasn't born in Germany Trump's
grandfather Friedrich Trump was born in
Germany came to the United States in
1885 this is not good and it actually
gets even worse Pat pointed out to me
that there's another moment during this
exact same press conference press
availability I guess you would call it
where Donald Trump twice says the word
oranges like the citrus fruit instead of
origins like the source of something and
again both times he seems unsure of what
he's saying something seems to glitch in
his head where he realizes he's saying
something wrong but it's almost like
beyond him to even control it take a
look and I hope that this investigation
now which is finished
it's totally finished no collusion no
obstruction
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation you look at the origin of
the investigation where it started how
it started who started it whether its
became or Comey or a lot of them where
does it go how high up in the white
house did it go you will all get
Pulitzer Prizes okay you're gonna all
get Pulitzer Prizes you should have
looked at it a long time ago and that's
the only thing that's disappointing to
me about the Muller report the Muller
report
I wish covered the oranges how it
started yeah what do you make of that
Pat I mean you can tell that this is
he's not so far gone that he doesn't
recognize he's having trouble saying
what he thinks he should be saying
there's definitely some recognition
there but it's a very strange behavior
he can definitely tell it he's saying it
wrong it's surprising to me that he
wouldn't just stick with a substitute
like pick a different word beginnings
what have you and just continue using
the
beginnings why does he have to keep
going back and trying to pronounce
origins correctly just give up on it
that would be my take I was thinking of
this story from when I was a kid as many
of you know I was born in Argentina my
dad was born in Argentina his dad was
born in Argentina and in Spanish there
are two words to say here there's the
word aqui and there's the word acha now
in Argentina in most situations
acha is more common but it kind of
depends on the particulars of the
circumstances and that's the one I was
basically familiarized with when I was
six years old um and when I moved to the
United States most of the Spanish
speakers that I was around in elementary
school at kindergarten and first grade
were from Puerto Rico and in Puerto Rico
it's much more common to say achey in
fact I would exclusively only hear them
say aqui so in my mind I associated aqui
with people born in Puerto Rico and akka
with people born in Argentina so once
when I was like six
I remember my dad said aqui and for some
reason I looked at him and I said dad
what were you born in Puerto Rico with
total sincerity and seriousness and he
said David no I I was born in Argentina
you know that my father was born in
Argentina I was born in Argentina you
were born in Argentina and I said oh
yeah that's right and so what when I see
Trump do this and say his dad was born
in Germany when he wasn't short of being
a little kid or suffering from some
actual cognitive decline I don't
understand how one can miss state where
their parent is from unless they don't
know them at all and Trump did know his
dad my mom is from Argentina
her dad is from Poland that's not
something I would forget if at some
point I say my mom was born in Poland
and went to Argentina something would be
very wrong with me I mean it would be I
I can only imagine it would be a medical
condition of some kind and people are
saying online it's a very dumb thing for
Trump to lie about the birthplace of his
father I don't think he's lying I think
something is wrong here and we've
interviewed mental health professionals
who believe something is very very wrong
here
and I want to hear from you what do you
think is going on here you can let us
know on our Instagram page david pakman
show you can find us on Instagram follow
me while you're there at David Pakman
part two of my interview with 20/20
Democratic presidential candidate Andrew
yang comes up right after this short
break
but there's a wacky and ridiculous
headline that appeared on screen on fox
news that's obviously really dumb but
it's actually also a serious thing that
I want to talk about which with you
which is the total misunderstanding of
Latin America that exists these
lower-third images matter that show up
at the bottom when you tune into MSNBC
or CNN or Fox News even before you
listen to what's being said to figure
out what the topic is to see if you're
interested you often will just read
what's at the bottom of the screen the
lower third as it's often called um and
when Donald Trump over the weekend
announced that he was going to be
cutting aid to three Latin American
countries El Salvador Guatemala and
Honduras these are three countries right
this is not Mexico these are three other
countries FoxNews erroneously
inadvertently wrote the headline that
Donald Trump cuts aid to three Mexican
countries that's what it said on screen
Trump cuts US aid to three Mexican
countries so yes hahaha they don't know
geography they don't know about Latin
America these are countries that many
people come to the u.s. from so they are
Mexican through Mexico so they are
Mexican countries fine it's nonsense and
Fox News apologized for it and then they
corrected it but there's actually a
really deep thing that I want to talk
about and this is the perfect
opportunity to talk about it and there's
a sort of geopolitical side and then
there's a personal side which I'll tell
you about this
so first the geopolitical lots of
Americans don't know about all of these
Latin American countries when they think
about immigration they sort of imagine
people from this mess of countries below
Mexico it's people who are basically
just like Mexicans they speak Spanish
who most importantly are trying to
invade the United State
through the southern border so it
doesn't really matter if they're coming
from Guatemala or Honduras or Costa Rica
Panama or Venezuela or wherever and of
course they're only coming from some of
these countries in any significant
numbers in the same way that they don't
care to know or understand the
differences between like single-payer
versus medicare-for-all versus a
nationalized healthcare system it's just
it's all communism in the minds of many
people they don't care or know the
differences between what's happening in
Mexico
versus what's happening in Honduras
versus Guatemala or the fact that these
countries have different indigenous
groups each of whom have different
cultures and different histories and
very often speak different languages in
addition to Spanish and they definitely
have no idea that the United States
relationships to these countries in the
last hundred years has been drastically
different if you consider the US history
in Nicaragua for example to the US
history with Costa Rica and Mexico as an
example there is very little in common
other than yeah a bunch of the people in
these countries speak Spanish so in a
sense the stupid-head line of Trump is
cutting aid to three Mexican countries
it's more accurate than you can imagine
in terms of the worldview that exists
for many of these right-wingers and
trumpets so that's on the geopolitical
side now on the personal individual sort
of identity politics I'd even relatively
educated people are very confused about
Latin America I have this funny anecdote
where someone I know has family has
cousins who live in a rural conservative
part of the United States and there was
a point in time where where the the the
cousins were sort of confused they've
somehow heard I David speaks Spanish oh
I speak Spanish yeah David speaks
Spanish he's from Argentina and they
said oh he's Mexican wait what he speaks
Spanish he's Mexican no he's from
Argentina that's a different country
it's in South America not in Central
America lots of countries speak Spanish
Mexican is a nationality oh but isn't
David's white right yet that's right he
is white and his ethnicity is you know
Ashkenazi Jewish but you can be from any
country
and speak any language and then it was
wait there are Jews in Mexico and the
answer is of course there are Jews in
Mexico but David's not from Mexico
dave is from Argentina so the stupid
headline is sadly I wish it weren't the
case I wish we could just laugh it off
as some dumb thing on fox news it
actually is a really good opportunity to
point out that there are a lot of
understandings out there about Latin
America and in the same way that many
people in the West see that jumble of
countries when you look at a map of
Africa as not particularly distinct and
only when you actually inform yourself
do you realize about countries that were
where French is spoken that are very
distinct from other parts of Africa
northern and southern Africa West Africa
and all of these different conflicts and
and sort of internal politics there's a
very similar sort of perspective with
Latin and South America and it doesn't
make any sense and this stupid headline
on Fox News as dumb as it is actually is
sort of opening the door to a lot of
that so I'm kind of glad to have the
opportunity to discuss it because I
don't know how else I would kind of
randomly bring it up but anyway Fox News
they apologized and who knows who they
blamed it doesn't even matter at this
point some kind of error in the control
room as they often say but that is
actually the perspective of many people
when they hear that these three
countries are no longer getting aid from
the United States what they imagine is
these are all countries where people
just come in over the us-mexico border
let's cut aid to all of them until they
do what we want and what that is never
exactly clear when you hear Trump say
they're not even doing anything for us
make sure you're following the show on
Instagram at David Pakman show we will
take a quick break
next I will be joined by David Ferriss
and we will talk about our Democrats
fighting dirty to use the term that he
used in terms of encouraging how
Democrats should behave last time he was
on are they fighting dirty yet or are
they not
David Farris joins me next okay so now
let's get into the the bar walk back as
I'm calling it exactly as I've been
saying for a week now Donald Trump's
Attorney General William bar is now
saying that his
four-page summary of the Moller report
isn't actually a summary of the full
investigation it was just as I told you
some things that he chose to say but
last week I started referring to what
Barr published as a supposed summary of
molar summary of the investigation as I
told you in the last story on today's
show we now know that the molar summary
of the full investigation is three to
four hundred pages long it's an
investigation that could have a million
or more pages of investigative data
evidence testimony and more documents
it obviously became untenable to
maintain that these four measly pages
from William Barr could respectably be
called a summary of the full
investigation so what William bard did
it's really very clever he snuck into a
letter that he put out over this weekend
that his four-page letter last weekend
is not actually a summary of the
investigation and this has barely gotten
any attention but it's so important I
want to go through the documents in the
articles with you CNN Justice Department
correspondent Laura Jarrett published
this latest letter from William Bar on
her Twitter account and this is just
amazing because most of the reporting on
this letter that were showing you is
about when will the report ultimately be
released and bar lists a whole bunch of
different things that need to be
retracted things that are classified all
these categories of things named by
William Barr that need to be retracted
but if you look closely at the bottom of
the first page you will see William bar
say my March 24 letter Bart now
specifically calling it it's just it's
just a letter that's all it is not a
summary not a report it's just a letter
my March 24 letter was not and did not
purport to be an exhaustive recounting
of the special counsels investigation or
report as my letter made clear my
notification to Congress and the public
provided pending the release of the
report a summary of its principal
conclusions that is what he considers to
be the bottom line and he goes on to say
quote I do not believe it would be in
the
public's interests for me to attempt to
summarize the full report or to release
it in cereal or piecemeal fashion that's
right we know that and now he's saying
it and he's right the document does not
call itself a summary per se it's a list
of what William Bar says are the most
relevant conclusions but despite William
bar now saying this seven days after he
released this thing trumpets and
corporate media and right-wing media and
even some left-wing media claimed utter
and complete exoneration on the basis of
this letter being a summary of the
entire report this the transparency of
this four-page letter as a political
document is very very clear this is a
walk back but a calculated one bar never
actually says everything that's in the
report is here what he said is the
important things from the report are in
this letter that is used for a week by
the 24-hour news cycle to claim that
this is it this is vindication this
means there's no evidence of obstruction
this this is a total clear vindication
of Donald Trump and everybody around him
and then William bar says listen that
was just what I thought it was the
principal conclusions that was never
actually meant to be a summary but the
cat is out of the bag the the horses
have left the stable so to speak here
and what we now recognized as
effectively a press release from William
bar a week in a day ago of four pages
was merely a pretext for Donald Trump
and his cronies to claim exoneration and
this is you know the thing about it Pat
it worked
I mean they're not stupid okay Trump
picked Barr specifically to manage the
release of this of this report Barr did
exactly what he was supposed to do which
is put out a political document that is
a pretext for Sean Hannity and Jeanine
Pirro and Trump and from jr. and
everybody to say it's over folks no
collusion t-shirts and hats and whatever
else and now we actually have to try to
walk back the misunderstandings which
they deliberately calculated and planned
congratulations to them I mean they did
it right I think William bara
successfully
prime the pump on this and you have to
wonder why did we even need his summary
to begin with like I understand he
wanted to put out the initial
conclusions and he wanted to make sure
that we had some understanding of what
went on with the molar report because it
was a matter of public interest and also
if the president was indeed compromised
by Russia we'd want to know that as soon
as possible but we waited a year and a
half two years for this investigation to
end I think we could wait a few more
weeks to actually see their mullah
report his itself
we don't need William bars summary
consider for a second if Democrats
didn't control the House of
Representatives right now we might never
get the truth I mean we still might not
well by the way we don't know ultimately
what it is that we're going to get
hopefully we will get it but if
Democrats didn't control the house there
is no chance that we're getting it and
key point as I said this is not a
document summarizing the probe it's a
press release PR friendly cheerleading
document meant specifically to serve as
the pretext for Trump to claim victory
go around the country claiming victory
which he did and it worked on lots of
Americans a lot of the individuals are
pretty dim-witted that are involved here
but the big picture of this scam was
executed very very well and I guess in
some sense I mean it's it's disgusting
but I've got to give them credit they
actually pulled it off let me know what
you think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show